6 42 here on good day las vegas and as
you see there metro sheriff joe lombardo
is now joining us for our weekly morning
cup of joe's segment sheriff good to see
you once again sir how are you this
morning
good morning john good to see you all
right let's get into things here
we've talked about across the state and
las vegas restrictions are slowly being
lifted
more people are visiting town once again
which is good for business but i imagine
uh metro is preparing for this uh the
increase to normal
uh visitation what are changes are being
seen in the resort quarter as we get
closer to summer
yeah that hopefully with the
proliferation of the vaccine and the
restrictions from the governor's office
they get uh lessened
as we move forward we'll see our economy
start to
turn on its head a little bit
that means tourism the increase in
tourism down in the strip corridor in
fremont street area and i don't know if
you recall
when we talked about numbers that's
about eight percent of what i have to
deal with on a daily basis and all my
calls for service
and daily work activity uh so we're
going to pull
a lot of the folks that we pulled put
into the neighborhoods during the
shutdown and
you know the cutbacks on the strip area
and put them back out on the
uh the tourist corridor area so we have
that omni presence uh
constantly which has a direct effect on
how people preserve
perceive uh their personal safety and
and the safety we can provide to the to
the area
um the only thing is that's troubling me
now is we're still
we're seeing some continuance of the
crime we experienced in late
last year um specifically to domestic
violence
um type homicides or murders
or violence associated with domestic
violence so we want to
keep our eye on that and the violence
that we saw late last year
in the strip corridor you know the
anxiety from cobia and hopefully these
people come out you know the roaring 20s
effect we want them to come out and
enjoy themselves but
you know with restraint and
responsibility well and of course
i wouldn't necessarily say it's
connected but we did see what happened
just last night out at the win
apparent murder suicide there i wouldn't
necessarily group it together but it is
certainly a violent activity
let's switch gears switch gears a little
bit sheriff some other complaints that
we've been hearing from viewers
not on the strip but out in the
community reckless driving street racing
we've seen some video on social media
what is metro doing about this issue and
what really can be done to try and crack
down on this
yeah that has reared its head here it's
usually cyclical
um you know you see people do that at
different times in a year and i don't
know what it is i don't know if it's
social media driven or not but
it's it's occurring across the united
states so a lot of the major city uh
police departments are experiencing the
same thing where these individuals come
together
they tie up an entire intersection they
film themselves posted on social media
you know the trick trick driving the
drag racing type events
and it requires us to have planet
flights prior to
so we have done that we have folks that
are uh
dedicated to that we become aware of it
and hopefully we can prevent it from
happening in the first place but when it
does occur
we have a pretty good task force
response to that type of incidence
now it's important for people to realize
our goal is to take people into custody
take their
vehicles into custody to try and prevent
it and issue citations
and at the last legislative session
the legislature raised a violation of
that type crime participating in trick
driving
and drag racing as a gross misdemeanor
so it's not
anything to sneeze at it isn't like a
simple thing you think you can get rid
of
or avoid easily um once we uh
encounter you it's a nuisance it blocks
the street but it's also obviously very
dangerous as well so if people see
something
certainly yes let police know that's
important john the piece of that is it's
it's also a misdemeanor to even be a
spectator
so if we show up and you just stand
there watching them and you're part of
we determine you're part of the fray
you can't get caught up in the criminal
charge
sheriff a couple of weeks ago we showed
you we showed rather viewers
a video that metro shared with us of the
shooting death of kamiya bird on i-15
that happened back in september
we got a lot of interest in that story
after it aired we saw a lot of comments
about it online
i think a lot of viewers want to know if
there's been any progress since then
where do things stand right now in the
cami bird case
unfortunately it's still at a standstill
yeah
and i appreciate everything you do to
help us in that in that space and
identify
a possible suspect but we didn't get any
uh positive response from the the
reviewing or the reconstituting the
investigation
we're still waiting for some viable
information and at this point
we've exhausted all our investigative
means and
we've run what we have been called in
about
to the ground and nothing positive has
come forward
we're classifying it as a road rage
incident we have
uh miss bird on video prior to the
shooting
driving in excess of 100 miles per hour
so we're thinking it's
probably a road rage incident but
unfortunately it doesn't matter
a person lost their life and it's
important for us to find out who did
it uh so we're gonna you know keep the
case open and hopefully uh
something comes our way in a positive
effect so we can
investigate this further just to clarify
you said miss byrd was driving at 100
miles an hour before the shooting
yes okay well that is a a different a
new detail i should say so
that might play in maybe someone
recognized that happening on that uh the
morning of september 16th sheriff
we appreciate you joining us once again
this morning if you at home have a
question for sheriff joe lombardo
you can submit it on our website
8newsnow.com
find out if it's answered every
wednesday